pizza time welcome back everyone to
stream of the galaxy my name is rocket
riley and today we're going to be
counting down the top 10 weirdest and
most unbelievable spider-man stories
we've ever seen
but before we get started if you're new
to the channel please hit the subscribe
button and click the bell icon to be
notified when we upload a new video
with the upcoming release of spider-man
no way home we thought it would be fun
to go over all of the craziest
spider-man stories we've seen in
television film and comics since this
movie is going to be cracking open the
multiverse like we've never seen before
watch closely because it's always
possible that some of these stories
could pop up as easter eggs or
references in no way home
no villain can outmatch jay jonah
jameson when it comes to absolutely
loathing spider-man
jameson is probably the most hateful
person towards spidey and their
relationship is one of the most well
known throughout all of the spider-man
comic shows and films
in this particular comic though jameson
gains more power than in any other story
he becomes the mayor of new york city
with this new power he is able to form
his very own anti-spider squad and
devotes a huge part of the city's budget
towards its biggest menace spider-man i
think it would be absolutely amazing to
see jk simmons portray this role in
becoming the new york city mayor and it
very well could happen someday since
he's appeared in both the tobey maguire
and the tom holland films
in this comic issue our friendly
neighborhood spider-man was turned into
a literal spider-man or man spider in
this case after the villain brainchild
used peter as a test subject in an
experiment peter was transformed into a
strange human spider hybrid
this actually happened more than once
with varying levels of creepiness
each time he went through this
transition into manspider he always
found a way to return back to his
original spider-man form
this story showcases a different battle
between doc and spider-man than the one
we saw in sam raimi's spider-man 2. in
this case spider-man's consciousness is
swapped with that of dr octopus letting
doc ock run free in spider-man's body
och then takes over peter's life with
the goal of being a better vigilante
than the old spider-man ever was and he
does a pretty good job of it turning him
into the superior spider-man with a new
costume and some mechanical arms doc ock
takes peter's life in a completely new
direction he improves it quite a bit
starting a large tech company called
parker industries
peter eventually gets his body back but
not until after doc gets a doctorate for
peter and makes him the ceo of a company
with hundreds of
employees this comic answers the
question of what would spider-man be
like if he was set in the era of crime
noir pulp comics and apparently he'd
have a black and white suit and use a
handgun to take down his enemies
spider-man noir is a retelling of the
spidey story set in 1933 his origin
story differs from the typical student
turned vigilante though in this version
spidey takes the role of a rugged
investigative reporter during the great
depression this character was actually
given an on-screen appearance and
spider-man into the spider-verse voiced
by nicholas cage these comics showcase
the darker side of spider-man who
regularly shoots his enemies with 45
caliber pistols even killing them in
some cases
one of the most infamous comic book
stories is spider-man one more day in
which peter makes a deal with the devil
mephisto in order to save aunt may from
dying after being shot
mephisto promises to heal aunt may at
the cost of his marriage with mary jane
watson peter agrees and everyone forgets
that mj and peter were married and
ant-may lives
peter however has to live with the fact
that he's no longer married to mj the
love of his life
many people have speculated that this
story could tie into the upcoming
spider-man no way home film because the
trailer seems somewhat similar to
spider-man's wish where everyone forgets
something about the character we'll just
have to wait and see if mephisto makes
an appearance in the movie alongside
doctor strange in this 1970s comic story
spider-man tries to get rid of his
powers thinking they cause more harm
than good instead of taking away his
powers the process instead causes peter
to grow four extra arms giving him the
same number of limbs as an actual spider
peter even alters his suit to fit these
extra limbs continuing to fight crime
and do good as the friendly six-armed
neighborhood spider-man
after fighting and defeating morbius who
is set to appear in a stand-alone film
in january of 2022
peter is able to revert back to his
original spider-man form with the help
of dr connors the comic series marvel
1602 oddly places the character of
spider-man in victorian england this
version of the character is known as the
spider or peter parkwa a spy from
scotland working for sir nicholas fury
the spider has all the same powers as
the traditional spider-man with the
addition of spinnerets on his arms that
produce organic webs similar to toby
maguire's version of spider-man
the biggest difference though is his
frilly 17th century costume which tries
to tie in some of the original spidey's
costume
peter parkout falls in love with
real-life historical figure virginia
dare the first child from england born
in the new world she acts as the story's
gwen stacy even losing her life at the
hands of norman osborne if there are
spiderman from the past obviously there
are some from the future too spider-man
2099 tells the story of miguel o'hara an
engineer at alcomax which is a
tyrannical corporation that basically
controls society in the year 2099
after miguel turns against his employers
alchemix has him scarred and altered
during a dangerous dna experiment this
experiment gives him the powers of
spider-man along with a few unique ones
of his own to become the spider-man of
the future this spider-man has organic
webs talons fangs and even telepathy he
also has a high-tech suit that allows
for gliding instead of swinging
this version of spider-man was recently
featured in an after credits scene for
spider-man into the spider-verse and in
the trailer for across the spider-verse
part 1 so it's likely that we'll get to
see more of his backstory in future
spider-verse installments one of the
oddest spider-man stories has to be the
story of spider-punk in a dystopian
world where an evil norman osborne rules
the united states the young hobart brown
or spider-punk leads the resistance
against him he sets out to liberate the
country from osborne's tyrannical
thunderbolt department an evil police
force armed with variable engagement
neurosensitive organic mesh or venom for
short with the power of punk rock and
his spider-like abilities hobart is able
to defeat osborne in his regime but only
after beating him up with his electric
guitar
all spider-man fans know that dr octopus
is one of the most iconic spider-man
villains but very few know about this
unbelievable story in this 70's comic
doc catches an elaborate scheme to get
married to spider-man's aunt may not
because he's in love with her but
because may has inherited a nuclear
plant in canada that doc ock wants for
himself after he's released from jail
dock hires aunt may as a housekeeper and
comes across a letter from a lawyer that
says she has inherited a nuclear
facility so he hides the letter kills
the lawyer who sent it and then tries to
marry mae so he can kill her and inherit
the nuclear facility for himself
obviously his plan doesn't work and
spider-man is able to stop the wedding
before they say i do
while there are lots of bizarre
spider-man stories this one definitely
tops the list
well that's gonna be all for the
craziest spider-man stories we've ever
seen if you enjoyed the video please hit
the like button and don't forget to
subscribe for more great content what do
you think did we miss any crazy
spider-man stories that should be added
to the list drop your thoughts in the
comment section below from everyone here
at stream in the galaxy we hope you have
a great day and thanks for watching
you